from shop floors to steel foundries from
pubs to production lines
there's barely a workplace nationwide
unaffected by the so-called pandemic
it's a new type of workplace crisis as
business owners like martha know all too
well
last week her stationary company had to
completely shut down
almost every member of staff told to
isolate
i have to say the seven years that i've
been running this business i think the
last couple of weeks have been
some of the hardest i think making the
decision to close business even for a
few days is something we've never had to
do before
so i really feel that we've had such
mixed messages and such
unclear guidance from the government
in industries like meat processing
problems are piling up
some have up to 10 of their workers
stuck at home
it means having to streamline and
prioritize cheaper products
you can't get away from it we cannot
keep our
you know this this spiraling increase
it's not sustainable something has to
change
and realistically how long do you think
it is before people start seeing
gaps on the shelves i think the
observant would already see that
actually the offer on the shelves is
different and i think this weekend is
the first hot weekend so coming up it's
for barbecue weekend
i think it's going to be quite a
challenging weekend for the industry
it's the alert that most people dread a
message to your phone
saying you'll have to stay in the house
for up to 10 days
but many business groups are saying that
the official guidance has shifted
slightly with more of an emphasis being
put on the app being
advisory they say it's left many unsure
what to do
there are other ways the government's at
least considering trying to ease the
pressure
rules could be relaxed for nhs staff
vital perhaps in a service
strained by backlog and all with covert
cases still rising
if the river is very full and the ground
is sodden
it doesn't take a very many uh covered
cases for the river to burst its banks
and that's what it's like in the nhs in
certain places at the moment
we're under real real pressure there are
trials being run
in places like this allowing staff to
keep working if they keep testing
negative
a blueprint perhaps and a lifeline
making sure that our frontline services
keep operating is absolutely crucial so
undoubtedly the testing program
has helped us keep operating suggestions
that app sensitivity might be dialed
down
for now it seems not happening an
economy on the cusp of reopening
still dictated to by a disease helen and
smith sky news